je suis pas très bon mais en tout cas il
ya vraiment de quoi s'amuser
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle monde connecté il
ya quelques jours j'ai testé la tique os
pro de maubreuil plutôt cool
si vous suivez mes vidéos vous savez
qu'à titre personnel j'ai une apple
watch series 2,6 un modèle mais
aujourd'hui on va tester une autre monde
connecté j'ai vraiment hâte parce que
j'avais vraiment très très très envie de
la tester c'est la galaxie wax de
samsung
elle a été annoncée il ya pas très
longtemps il me fait de l'oeil depuis un
bon petit moment sur le papier en tout
cas comme je les ai vu en vidéo j'ai
trouvé vraiment intéressante donc
combattre dans cette vidéo c'est que on
bat le nox et on va regarder ce qui à
l'intérieur
assez rapidement en fuite je les couper
et on se retrouvera dans quelques jours
pour voir la suite alors j'ai coupé pour
vous ça va durer le temps d'un
claquement de doigts pour moi ça va être
quelques jours parce qu'il faut que la
mettre aux poignets que je la teste que
je fasse plein de choses avec mes vous
inquiétez pas on garde tout dans cette
vidéo on y va voilà la boîte 46 mm
bluetooth galaxie web bon plutôt
efficace plutôt sympa l'ong batterie est
life auto fitness workout ya pas mal de
choses résistante à l'eau jusqu'à 50
mètres c'est ce qu'on va voir
la voilà j'aime beaucoup le design les
deux boutons intégrés sur le côté sont
vraiment classe le cadre très joli
bracelet plastique plutôt pas mal à voir
contre le porte mais comme ça en tout
cas je la trouve assez séduisante à
l'intérieur de la boîte en dessous on va
se retrouver avec des compartiments dans
ce compartiment là toute la partie pour
le recharger en micro usb et dans le
deuxième compartiment nous avons vont à
ce récent bracelet un deuxième bracelet
un peu plus petit que le premier ce doit
être le bloc de recherche avec la
connectique micro-usb comment est-ce
qu'elle va se positionner là dedans je
pense qu'on la positionne comme ça
plutôt pas mal réussi je trouve que
l'idée est bien esthétiquement c'est
vraiment ça fait un joli objet aussi
ensuite on a à l'intérieur de la doc et
je crois que on a fait le tour la
question d'un point de vue purement
esthétique si je la compare avec la
tique watchfrog jaccottet sensiblement
similaire va y avoir une différence si
au niveau du design là elle paraîtra
plus fine parce que vous avez la grande
bordure en métal là et du noir en bas la
tique watch prochain l inverse si on met
à côté une apple watch elle paraîtra un
peu plus haute
ce que je vous propose maintenant c'est
de tout simplement la mettre au poignet
je vais la garder quelques jours je
pouvoir la tester comme ça un peu de
tous les côtés voir un peu ce qu'elle
dit au niveau des applications est ce
que je la trouve confort pack confort
intéressante pas intéressante c'est ce
que j'aime sur ses montres
ferrante d'apple watch pourtant j'adore
les appels au match et les bracelets qui
va pas ces bracelets là vous arrache
tout simplement les poils c'est une
vraie torture race est d'origine il faut
les changer là en tout cas sur celle là
vraiment bien très facilement sa place
on va donc la tester et on se retrouve
d'ici quelques jours le temps d'un clic
ça fait maintenant quelques jours que je
teste la galaxie mauvaise je peux enfin
vous dire ce que je pense et vous allez
voir on n'est pas au bout de nos
surprises
la toute première chose que j'aime dans
cette watch c'est cette molette qui vous
permet de naviguer extrêmement
facilement sas pour ça génial nous avons
plus en retours donc une vraie sensation
à chaque fois qu'on bouge c'est hyper
confort hyper agréable et ça pour le
coup c'est vrai que ça change un peu
vous avez la possibilité bien évidemment
de customiser votre cadran vous mettez
le cadran vous voulez vous n'avez pas
mal an choix vous en avez énormément à
vous de choisir celui qui vous
correspond le mieux moi j'aime beaucoup
celui par défaut je trouve très
classieux donc je le garde toutes les
informations de base
la météo sur l'eau et les degrés le
nombre de pas ici la batterie de ma
montre le jour bien évidemment leur
ai-je et les notifications qui vont
arriver d'un côté ou de l'autre
et sache qu'on sort vraiment bien quand
je descends l'ajax et à tous mais
raccourcie pour venir dans les
paramètres de ma montre donc j'ai tous
les paramètres qui sont réglables ici au
niveau du cadran du son de l'affichage
avancis fin il ya pas mal de choses mais
je dois reconnaître que ça aussi c'est
super pratique peut mettre en mode avion
je peux régler la luminosité la son côté
j'ai deux boutons qui sont extrêmement
discret le bouton du bas me permet
d'arriver dans toutes mes applications
pour pouvoir naviguer bouger et ensuite
choisir ce dont j'ai besoin tandis que
le bouton du haut mais permet de revenir
au menu du départ en soi yport à droite
jacques ses atouts mais widgets toute ma
partie sport je peux ajouter des
contacts créés un rappel toutes mes
applications santé
ça c'est vraiment aussi super pratique
qui tandis que quand je lis sur la
gauche
j'ai toutes mes notification cette
galaxie watch existe dans deux modèles
soit 42 mm soit 46 mm celle que j'ai au
poignet moi c'est la 46 mm elle a un
écran super amoled de 1,3 pouces 360 par
360 pixels
elle est bien évidemment étanche jusqu'à
50 mètres vous avez la fonction plus
always zone pour toujours avoir vos
informations à l'écran en termes de
performance vous avez un processeur de
1,15 giguère vous avez 4 go de stockage
de l'intérieur et 0,75 giga octet de ram
vous avez du bluetooth 4.2 du nfc pour
le paiement dématérialisé puis c'est une
montre qui est assez légère parce
qu'elle fait en tout 63 g et elle a une
batterie de 472 millions terreur qui lui
permet de tenir quatre jours ça bien
évidemment ça dépend
votre utilisation ça dépend si vous êtes
gourmand ou pas et ça dépend si les
réglages de vos applications point de
recueil sur cette montre bixby n'est
toujours pas en français si vous voulez
parler bixby il faut le faire mais dans
la langue de shakespeare
what time is it vous avez la possibilité
de le régler en anglais et dans d'autres
langues que je ne maîtrise pas et ça
pour le coup c'est vrai que c'est quand
même un point d'eux regrettant cette
montre alors vous avez des scieries
google assistant qui sont complètement
en français samsung tard d'arriérés
bixby en français c'est vraiment dommage
parce que pour le coup les autres
occupent le terrain samsung n'est pas
présent là dessus sur la langue de
molière quand est ce que samsung va
arriver avec des xvi en france est pour
l'instant toujours pas d'infos mais on
patiente mon pasteur en patientant
patiente par contre quand application il
ya franchement de quoi faire déjà de
base vous avez énormément de choses
installés mais vous pouvez en plus
vraiment rajouter vous avez bien
évidemment la possibilité de passer vos
appels téléphoniques directement depuis
votre montre tous vos contacts toutes
les informations santé est directement
de samsung le nombre de calories brûlées
le nombre de pas le nombre d'états je
montais voyez aujourd'hui n'a pas été
complètement dingue l'exercice vous
pouvez faire un nouvel entraînement
si vous voulez vous entraînez vous
pouvez faire de la courbe de la marche
du vélo de la natation tapis de course 2
ou d'appartements tout ce que vous
voulez peut même ajouter directement vos
exercices des abdos développé-couché
développer des épaules enfin il ya pas
mal de choses pour moi
cette montre elle est vraiment vraiment
bien pour tous les sportifs mais pas que
maintenant ce qui est vraiment bien dans
ses applications c'est que votre montre
elle se connecte directement en wifi
vous allez dans vos paramètres d'en
avant d'en collection et vous avez si
vos connexions wifi vous êtes connecté
directement à votre box si vous n'êtes
pas obligé de passer par votre
smartphone ça c'est un point qui est
plutôt pas mal
vous êtes donc complètement indépendante
pour venir télécharger des applications
sur votre store et les crocos c'est
génial parce que vous avez accès à
énormément de choses
alors il ya des choses qui sont
intéressants d'autres qui le sont
beaucoup moins en tout cas ce qui est
vraiment vraiment vraiment génial c'est
que vous avez un choix qui est
complètement énorme et que vous pouvez
vraiment vraiment vraiment personnaliser
votre montre en mettant tout ce que vous
voulez le sud est
des choses pratiques de tous et ça c'est
vraiment bien bien évidemment un service
de météo des alarmes l'horloge mondial
le calendrier bon big b says a déjà
montré l'altimètre qui peut être
vraiment pratique pour tous les sportifs
et pour ceux qui partent en montagne
vous avez donc votre altimètre votre
baromètre en hectopascals plutôt cool et
ça quand tout ce qu'ils vont faire du
voyage en montagne croyez-moi ça peut
être très pratique vous avez aussi des
applications avec différentes news et
bien évidemment des petits jeux comme le
fameux snec du 33 10 qui est pour le
coup reste un très grand classique et
avec ça on peut s'amuser
je suis pas très très bon mais en tout
cas il ya vraiment de quoi s'amuser mais
vous avez aussi accès à votre quantité
d'eau que vous avez vu vous pouvez donc
enregistrer la quantité d'eau que vous
avez bu avoir un vrai suivi on parle que
d'eux ici on ne parle pas d'autre chose
mais je trouve que c'est vraiment très
très très pratique vous pouvez aussi
enregistrer vos données de caféine voir
si vous avez bu trop de café enfin ça
permet vraiment d'aller très loin dans
votre personnalisation vous avez bien
sûr la possibilité de mesurer votre
rythme cardiaque directement ici faire
un point sur votre rythme la semaine
voir à chaque date comme ça au moins je
peux voir où j'en suis
voir si je suis stressé pas stressé ça
permet d'avoir des données qui sont
relativement fiable 80 bpm supérieur à
la plage moyenne de repos je peut
tailler et ensuite je mets dans quel
état je suis si je suis au repos
générale après un exercice avant un
exercice fatigué souffrent excité
surpris énervé voilà amoureux je suis
amoureux sont des petits outils qui vous
permette effectivement de voir où est ce
que vous en êtes et ça ça peut être pas
mal notamment pour des personnes qui
souffrent de maladies cardiovasculaires
ça peut leur permettre d'avoir en tout
cas un petit suivi vous avez aussi toute
la partie concernant votre respiration
pour voir vous en mettre et notamment
par rapport au stress alors là vous
pouvez effectivement respirez vous
définir un objectif
inspirez expirez
à la différence de ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur l'apple watch là dessus
vous n'avez pas de vibrations au niveau
du bracelet sur l'apple watch vous
l'avions niveau d'inspiration et vous en
avez au niveau de l'expiration là vous
avez un petit son qui est plutôt cool
mais bon on n'a pas du tout la même
sensation vous pouvez mesurer votre
niveau de stress niveau de stress moyens
j'aime beaucoup cette monde parce que je
trouve effectivement extrêmement
personnalisable avec toutes les
applications que vous avez de supporters
vraiment ce que vous voulez la
navigation est super intuitive avec
cette sensation sous le doigt on sait
vraiment où on en est
pour ça vraiment vraiment agréable en
plus le fait d'avoir un écran super
amoled vous donne quelque chose
d'extrêmement punchy beaucoup de lumière
bon vous l'aurez compris et que cette
galaxie web on peut faire énormément de
choses la seule limite c'est vous c'est
ce que vous voulez télécharger ce que
vous voulez mettre à l'intérieur alors
pour moi cette montre elle se destine
pas uniquement aux amoureux de fitness
comme beaucoup de monde connecté cette
galaxie watch elle s'adresse à monsieur
et madame tout le monde à tous ceux qui
veulent une monte utile pratique qui
vous permettra de savoir où est-ce que
vous en êtes dans votre journée par
rapport au stress par rapport à votre
rythme cardiaque pour pouvoir gérer vos
agendas pour pouvoir gérer beaucoup de
fils écouter de la musique regarder même
des vidéos dessus pouvoir jouer pour moi
cette monde c'est une extension réel des
smartphones tout directement dessus
connectable en plus en wifi j'adore le
design
j'adore cette petite molette le bracelet
très facile attaché je la trouve
vraiment super et je ne peux que vous la
recommande et si elle vous intéresse et
l'air moins 350 euros vous ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description
je voulais déjà dit les banques
collectées c'est un sujet qui
m'intéresse beaucoup l'autre jour on a
testé la tigresse pro de maubreuil qui
est là il y en a d'autres aussi à tester
on va regarder d'ici quelques temps là
ni band 3 2 xiaomi qui a été annoncé il
ya un trois semaines quinze jours trois
semaines on l'était directement à milan
pour pouvoir vous en parlait il ya aussi
la pelouse lilloise series 4 était
présenté par apple il ya pas très
longtemps fin il ya pas mal de monde
connecté donc on va continuer à en
parler je récupère et d'autres pour vous
en parler je pense que c'est vraiment
très intéressant parce que là monde
connecté devient vraiment un accessoire
qui se démocratise de plus en plus les
applications développées sont plus en
plus nombreux il ya plein de choses à
faire mais qu'est ce qu'on s'est
vraiment passé ou non dit
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire on reste connectés vous ne
posez toutes vos questions suggestions
interrogations directement en bas et
quant à moi donne rendez vous très
prochainement pour de nombreux tests ici
il ya plein de produits tous les côtés
il ya plein de choses à voir by claude à
tester vos qu'on fait une seule chose on
s'abonne et on reste connectés
[Musique]